girl first of all I cannot tell you how
thrilled we at UT are for this is us I
feel like your character is one of the
most relatable characters that we've
seen on TV in a really long time that's
because I live across the line what
really drew you to this role in
particular oh well aside from the fact
that I can completely relate to you know
having issues with being a plus-size
girl in the business but also just being
different you don't see women like this
on television I think it's so important
for women to see themselves on
television and you know they're not all
these beautiful size zeros and so it's
awesome that not only is there a great
story to tell but it's a different type
of character and a different type of
story so you won't be fat friends sure
where but I'm gonna lose the weight he
actually have named you one of our
breakout star teasin oh yeah thank you
much is going good that makes me feel
super special no we thank you done such
a phenomenal job in this role and we
think that great things are headed your
way so we wanted to just give you that
to really kick off the season for you oh
thank you so much look at this
you